1900 Radin 58 players here we go c5
smith Tamura no no oh my goodness that
would have been really bad
watch over d4 and okay what does my
knight think he's doing
d4 isn't a whole yet I wonder if this is
still a good idea I want to get this
beep on working let's do that
I'm gonna take the more advanced tonight
more advanced Knight is where I want to
be break down this chop on this square
first go here work that pond into a pin
if push it's not secure enough bishop
here maybe although now it's back up
keep tension between the books I guess
soften up the King side a little bit I
actually have a slight lead timewise I
don't know if that was really a good
idea let's do this take with the pawn my
bishop needs to do something else well
there's no I get this pawn working now
keep going
the game plan here is break down this
pawn pawn is pinned here watch over this
square Jeb my knight in here next oh
right here my rook working finally their
Kings the more vulnerable think I almost
Mouse slip that 25 seconds 25 seconds
paan push hard push I want to break this
down I better have something that pun is
extremely dangerous Bishop here oh this
is good I think bishop there would have
been was needed here no matter what
check and then just advance it wasn't a
good idea I don't have any time
fortunately back to tournament wow what
a start
twos okay twos okay I'll keep my
structure okay so they gave it the
bishop pair what do they have his
compensation not seeing it I have a dark
square bishop I'd like to post up right
here he's a monster he's officially a
monster the Queen is paralyzed crack at
the pawns that aren't dark squares get
this pawn next the Knights probably
going to move oh my goodness this is
close to mate it's gonna be me if the
night if the knight blocks let's do this
I think there's a couple checks right
around the corner right around the
corner let's pin this knight in an
attack on attack the knight if the
knight moves I could know if the night
plays here it's a different story where
is this mate
as close to me me and one and then two
there it is you know it was close close
to having made their six a bunch of
sixes up there
John Madden is up there okay
stay focused stay focused here get
developed
okay and now with this square being
weakened I can once again look to jump
in that square quickly even if Bishop
III I'm there in time to defend c5 and I
think there no matter what get my light
square Bishop working get my b5 pawn
working they're coming at me in the
meantime and I keep this structure as is
let's kick this night around a little
bit
he's out of play it's a bit loose okay
and post up here this Knight is in some
trouble I'm gonna take him I don't think
my light square Bishop could have done
anything anyway what do you do about
this okay let's give a check my knight
is a monster I'm not sure what I'm even
doing with that move if I give up my
darts for Bishop I'd like to have my
queen where like I might Queen on e5 I
make that happen
let's try this again you know what
thinking about giving up my dark square
bishop alright my rook for their dark
square Bishop let's just come back
floundering a bit okay now let's do this
and are they really going to get over
here let's do this and hide behind their
pond hopefully okay now to be very
careful let's do this and I want my
Queen to be able to breathe the bishops
gonna come there I grab that pot and
then just crash through
that's dangerous that is what you call
very dangerous I think I have to do that
somehow that's actually defending where
is it oh my goodness I'm down on time oh
that's what happens when you're looking
for a defensive moves your clock ticks
oh but weighing on somebody might quick
resign right after that oh I know this
guy gave me beating Wow Wow I was too
too afraid of that thorn it's too afraid
of the thorn and then somebody was
somebody who had some sympathy for me
they're like you know what I I see you
last night I see you lies that King
Larry quick resigned to you I feel bad
don't feel bad don't feel bad
oh man just like that that's it that was
a shocker right there huh that was a
shocker out of nowhere
boom okay with the red flag you my
friend are out of time it said you spent
too much time trying to defend shame on
you Oh a Knight takes pawn is available
give me the dark Sara Bishop break down
this pawn if it's defended it's not
being defended okay get my rooks working
oh man
okay Queen trades and let's get rid of
the bishop and so I think in the heavy
piece ending I do better break this down
Pond could restrict this rook okay
Oh hmm hang on okay
and keep my king defending that rook
can't do anything now they're pawns
can't do anything now
what's my King doing not much not much
oh that's my move
it's my move right there I wasn't moving
there for a second
oh look check rook check okay okay I got
that pawn time I gotta watch out for the
time huh very important detail that time
watch my base point I guess I'm quite
defensive right now and I let need some
time burners need some time burners
that's not really working
where are they four seconds is not a lot
of time there time burners Oh No aho
they did something sneaky right there
they had they had my Brooke but they
were down on time 20 20 18 I was really
fortunate actually too after I lost that
game to have somebody quick resign it
gave me a quick boost kind of right back
it gave me hope it gave me hope and let
me challenge this your right away right
away and I need to get castled I really
want to do this no oh hang on get this
guy out of there break that pin no way
could this work keep my knight around
over here the bishop is now shut down
I'm gonna get this pawn okay I have
there's a there's enough defense over
here the knight is an excellent defender
hon push let's just take that
what's my rook doing somebody tell me
what my rook is doing I'm asking for
trouble right now my king and queen are
on the same file I just want to UM oh my
goodness
this is not the this is not a good idea
Oh Rupp takes here maybe I can't take
with my queen I'm in big trouble I'm in
big trouble
oh my goodness
I'm gonna defend it like this oh this is
gonna be crushing 12 seconds once again
I'm having to defend Queen Shack here
instead of age three would have been a
killer the trade can move a lot faster
now get out of the pin 11 seconds hon
push probably no matter what tricky
discoveries okay give me this pawn and
then do what next they're down on time
back determine forty two thirty seven
thirty twenty six twenty five this is
the one I played in round one isn't it
that got way too scary man when when
you're on the defensive that time just
gets eaten right up and this time right
here is garbage look at that negative
149 a lot of help that is I gotta go
back here and my opponents knocking
we're gonna move I guess they quit after
that first round or second round back to
tournament quick win I need that
definitely need that 4237 okay see five
big surprise launch an H pawn okay he's
gonna be a thorn hopefully and there's
not going to be a great attack now is
there okay
okay let's kill that [ __ ] up
probably sacrificed there looks good
Oh Oh for a second I thought the night
could go here okay counter-attacking
challenge this night they take here very
happy with that
my other night working this pot to be
taken now at Camp this pond to be taken
okay I have to watch over this there was
ready to be a fork
okay now everything is finally covered I
could take this pond my nights are not
going to be trapped are they take that
oh this nights dead okay
where are the time burners oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh that would have
been bad the bishop was gonna play here
now I can I have this watched over if
Bishop takes I take like this it feels
like it's close to mate very close to me
there's a check Chuck for the tricky
checks it was to me I dropped another
piece oh I dropped her Brooke oh my
goodness I meant to go to the seventh
I'm a big trouble sneaky pond attack huh
no way did you grab that pond oh you
can't recover from this oh that's me oh
it's it's no matter what's me Oh too
many mouths lips
one too many that's all you need one
Mouse lip okay come on now I have to do
stuff which is called reckless reckless
stuff reckless stuff looking for cheap
tricks
where are the cheap tricks the cheap
tricks assault how much time is left in
this can I somehow get this mmm
dropping his palm he's defended
Pond push man that was a high drop that
that piece on c6 and then it was
downhill fast wasn't it very downhill
get my Bishop out now there's a
discovered trick with Bishop b5
I'm also on this night right now if
Queen takes I give a check so this was a
mistake the Queen could give a check in
each for I just blocked though to get
this back trades if Bishop takes I'll
take with the pond I want to keep the
Queen on the board need to win quick but
it doesn't look like it's gonna happen
or is it I'm on the bishop and me aged
seven the bishop moves it's age 7 age 7
is on f5 I guess okay I have this
covered otherwise Queen h4 would be very
strong castle Queen here get here
that'll be seen I still think it's a
good idea or even Queen Queen here
pointing at f7 they don't have any time
doesn't matter
back to tournament 49 I'm Way off 85
72-68 you can't win if you have what if
you have two losses there's no way
there's no way no one has ever done it
before have they we're gonna see about
it that deep on can't move now you can't
move okay
take that pawn I'm defending this f4 I
dropped back my other pawn working I get
my knight working actually I don't have
to take it he's caught a crossfire my
LightSquared bishop working I'm actually
threatening to take and then get the
bishop yeah I think that that's more
accurate he's pinned he can't go
anywhere anyhow the King should probably
just throw himself in the corner and
let's just complete my development rook
here pawn push and then I developed with
tempo but this rook is gone now this is
gone my rook is gone but I'm up a minor
piece fine with clean trades stop that
rook from having any activity Bishop's
around adjacent diagonals and secure my
bishops position March this pawn on
onward the rook is gonna get active here
no matter what here no matter what
King position pun up okay get behind
this passed pawn I have this square
covered as well
okay that's covered drop back don't have
any x 65 105 90-84 70 68 okay before I
have to turn my HP on I have to do
reckless stuff very reckless stuff
I got that not giving up there dark
square bishop so that's where the
implication that that Bishop is now a
very very good defender take this Knight
out of there at this pawn rolling Bishop
h3 and f5 get out of my house that's the
get out of my house move although I
don't want to take because it opens up
the H file maybe I'll take once I get a
little bit more development in rook F 1
and then f5 is the plan I'll take that
still watching f4 watch out for me here
don't go too far away actually just do
this no matter what I don't need more
support for it open the G file up G file
is where I want to be starting with the
Queen and then maybe the rook mate
threats have to be there
where are the mates oh right here
let's check it's got to be made soon it
takes
here here here are one of the dark
squares f 2 f 4 f 6 you know that the
clock run know exactly what I don't need
okay they resign 83 125 110 104 88 88 83
how much time is left
11 minutes 11 minute whirring sneaky ah
you see these are the cheap things they
have to go for the stuff I was talking
about before somebody asked what should
you not be doing think play hope chest
that's exactly what I'm doing right now
hope chest
I'm hoping the night is taken take that
night I hope you take them I still hope
you take them somehow and I think it's
good still uh-oh I take spy on h1 h1
it's better than each one each what's
better than h2 h1 sometimes look out
hang on i boosted up their triple digits
100 no way Oh quick resigner hang on
boosting boosting up the ranks boost
moving up the ranks no way no way it's
not gonna hang on what's going on is
this is this some April Fool's joke this
is way too late this is 15 days late 16
16 days late this is supposed to come in
April first
Oh watch out for f2 whoa hang on dark
square Bishop God just like that and
here's my epoch out on the Queen support
the night
it's whoa it's very windy out did you
hear that it's very windy in PA right
now very windy oh I dropped a bishop oh
my goodness why did I drop a bishop why
did I drop that Bishop is the queen
cause to trap somehow she might be
take like no that's not good is it the
Knights now running the risk of just
being trapped he's close to being
trapped now okay okay now the Knights
cooked the knight is cooked I take that
night okay
dodged a bullet there dodged a bullet
hang on come over here hang on to these
pawns stay active rook stay active grab
this pawn should plate here I'll take
this one though
and come back on the fifth the fifth
rank is the new seventh it's very good
there's a lot of black pawns there oh
they're all falling I'm okay with trades
another trade right here rooks are off
the board just take care no matter what
push your pawn get your king up take
like this no pawns no stalemates no
stalemates don't allow stalemate in
position
King position King position mate back to
tournament 153 145 144 oh man confuse
ray a lot a lot of players I think we're
feeling bad for me or something oh how
quick resign don't do that don't do that
you just start trouble you just end up
starting trouble with that okay let's
let's attack Oh
let's go here are they're gonna
sacrifice their shoot this night away
shoo that night away no way they
wouldn't take their word they probably
should oh it's so dangerous over here
it's so dangerous watch out for g2o the
queen is gone she's gone
Knight right here if the knight tries to
get to this square
oh this is scary I'm gonna give that up
take him just take him already oh did I
really want to do that oh my goodness
where's my I can't think he's going oh
man oh my goodness can I somehow tackle
that pun oh okay I got a tricky Fork
watch out and it's double check and not
double check discover check and just
like that the tables turn with the
tricky money okay position the bishop
get my king in a good position grab
these pawns pac-man mode no stalemates
no stalemates don't let any time come
off your clock whatever you do just run
like the wind blows Forrest Gump mode
who knows what I'm talking about just
move your pond I'm just doing this
because I think it's a good way to avoid
stalemate hopefully back to tournament
173 185 173 144 John Madden John Madden
mr. X isn't mr. X's and O's Oh a mouse
lip to begin come on let's go oh they're
gonna gain some space they might break
down white squares hopefully okay that's
dangerous it's dangerous there's gonna
be a check I think I could actually get
that night let's see if I'm right about
that
not so fast
not so fast I have to pin this guy and I
have to get a pawn out of it not a good
situation of being but is there tricky
stuff that it could maybe be getting get
that pond somehow okay I'm on that
Bishop there could be what oh the
bishops trapped he's
kind of isn't he it's gonna be a fork
okay I have a strong night I think could
I support him I shouldn't have done that
move so soon
King position King position came
physician King position tack that pon
get this pawn rolling Oh my rook is
trapped that stings
uh I have nothing oh there's not gonna
be any time not even a tricky and I
could save the day candy no way no way
definitely not now oh I'm checkmated I
was wondering I thought my opponent lost
on time oh man I actually had some hope
even though it was that unbalanced
position that night getting to d3 was
too much to handle is this guy gonna
move four minutes remaining I have three
losses you can't come back from three
losses wow this guy finally moved oh he
was giving me a one ninety one another
they're throwing it at me
they're throwing these at me I have a
chance I have a chance maybe can I get
another one is there another win not
long off grab some space actually from
Knight played here that would have been
a bad move that for because of Queen h4
exactly so if the knight played there
and I pre moved that for it wouldn't
have been a good thing at all
man clean eat too and then f5 or maybe
f5 right away actually if castles like
it's a con h7 and then play and thence
and then play Knight g5 Queen h4 stuff
watch over watch over I'm f2 this is
available this is also available let's
watch over this clean takes here should
have done that the bishop is a bit short
on squares is it not let's get out of
pins Knight here to here okay now comes
with the fork and I think actually after
Queen here I have seeds free and the
bishop is crunched if counter-attack I
throw a check in I know I could just
take like this let's check I move over
with my King and the bishop is stuck
actually guarding Oscar is however [ __ ]
no I have my rope defendant I thought
for a second I couldn't capture how much
time is remaining for 3 minutes it's 3
minutes I have this covered okay and now
pawn push bishop here get on this
diagonal right here okay tricky
discovery I think the queen is lost by
force somehow somehow she's lost by
force my knight can move and give check
porn detail double check and the queen
is gone this game isn't gonna finish
here no matter what
here no matter what here no matter what
I don't want any time to come off the
clock here no matter what point four
seconds back to chairman 2:11 Oh John
man's running away 1:25 again I wouldn't
have been anywhere close I don't have
been anywhere close without these quick
resign errs without the quick resign
errs
okay let's weasel my night around in
this night and then maybe pile up on it
on f3 pile up on the pin piece this is
this is already a dead tournament
there's no way to get first
I'm just hoping for what I'm hoping to
maintain that wasn't a good idea by the
way I'm hoping to maintain second double
up with the rooks they crashed through
on that square tonight right here no
pawn push although the rook is the
night's gonna be brutal on this square
gotta chase him away okay back here
focus on f3 it's gonna be taken I want
to get to age three age three is where I
want to be here I think no matter what
is a good idea or is it clean here maybe
I give a check first clean age through
the g2 Oh
they've already been assigned Oh second
place okay ah man what an ugly
tournament right across the board good
games 285 211 208 201 186 messy messy
messy messy messy okay